はるなんで髪の毛は軽くしたいななんかこういうの使うと1日だけ金髪になれるらしい
です
学生さんとバター髪の毛染めると怒られちゃうじゃないですか
だから学生だったわねこれが使ってねハリアテクノ1日だけ金箔とかにすればすごい
いいと思うんですよ
ちゃらーはいことは次節で皆さん春にあったってことはあると思うんですよ
いろんな場所あの冬に出るでやっぱりこの天気がいいんだけど外に行きたくなっちゃう
外にも行きましたかパルサーことでファンの人もしませんうわしてません医薬きました
いいところであるんですけど残念ながら僕は佐藤が嫌いなのでできればいけるんだけど
やっぱり何やかんややっぱり春だと移動することが多くなるんですよ外に出る
とかね外に比較的まだ出るようになったんですけども外に出る時皆さん何も家ができ
ますか
スマホライフ家の鍵位
そう6タブ脳みそおかしいレベルでものをよくなくしてしまいますそこでちょっと
すごいものを見つけましたこちらこの中に入ってるんですけどちょっと開けてみ
ましょういやこれまずネットで見つけたんですけど見たときまずで画期的すぎてこれは
まずで買った方がいいなと思いました
秋田こちらマグますマグ結ぼうとブルファ胸ティックキーリングホルダーもよりこう
いうキーホルダーです
けれどもこれは後で食べたときは
喋っと思ったわけですよで何がヤバイかって言いますと簡単に言うと章強力な
マグネットを搭載した
瞬時に着脱可能なマグネット9リングホルダーが値段がなんと5000円です
振ったっけまあいわゆるアレでしょ金見ながら他のキーケースといってもいいでるん
ですたとえばここに金属がありますここにこれをぶん投げてみましょう
[音楽]
ということなんですよこれ張正男磁石らしいですよ磁力がめちゃくちゃ強いんですよ
挙げてみましても中身はでいたって小さいんですよねもうほんとこれくらいのサイズ感
等でも磁石だがナンバー電化製品のところに近づけたくないんですよねまたこれどう
使うの
そういうことを今日極刑こうやって
これ俺すごくするけど磁石が協力の上に死にやすい腕重ねれば指とれたぜ
マークつきましたこういうことですねこっちに磁石そしてこっちにもチェックこういう
感じで多分ズボンとファンに内側にこれを入れて卒塔婆にここを入れる感じですただ
これは船が一歩間違えたら死ぬなんて強力な磁石ほどひっつく時の強さがすごいんで誰
これで多くジャン多くじゃんでこれをこうするとでもう待って応援のため日々だけ挟ま
ないでけど本当に行きます
怖いよ
パパ
あってゆくらちょっとかなり白く強い者なんですけどもこれはキー型として使うわけ
ですよやってみましょうもいう感じかな
こことかにこれより先に入れます豪やってここにこれを
食べもこれでキー検査を完成しております関係なくたらもうキーケースの声数でまとめ
てるんですよ俺が重いなんて思ったんでこれは例えばこういう気鋭 bing でね
こういうキーティングとこつけるってここに通したら本で結構離れづらいなっている
可能性がありますね金属リングがある車のカギとも積んでそうなるとこれだけつけたら
もうほい大きな鍵のケース
入らないなっていう感じなんだと思いますこれズボンのポケットに入れておけば
これはこうやってくっつくんだと思いますホラーでパッチリくっつけますねこれだが
あまりそれでも取れないと思う動いてはくれない
あえて言うかと次世代の急傾斜らしいですこれがこの弱
すごいということもこの弱があればいろんなものをズボンのポケットからコブラ酒
てあげると思うんですよちょっとどこまでぶら下げたら受けることができるかゼッケン
してみようと思います
センっ
愛という間にいろんなものをぶら下げて行ってみましょうまずは sd カード
リーダー
パソコンをちゃう人は sp カードが読み込めないと苦しいことが多いですから恋の
なく者っていいねこういうの普通にも強めているとすごい便利かなと思います
素晴らしい
[音楽]
これならいつでも sd カード読み込みますねすごいまずそれも続いてヒゲ剃っ男性
のみなさん
髭剃り忘れると困っちゃいますよねそんな時に行ったらヒゲそれができるようにここに
ついているとすごい便利じゃないでしょうか
つけてみましょう
[音楽]
荒山に愛宕山気持ち続いてはさみハサミとかも普通に持ち上げたかっこいいですよね
サメここで挟みに何がきた後にくるくるくるくる
脚気病したんでますがこれいいと思うんですがこうやって紙ジャケこれできるじゃない
ですか
右上て切って切り終わった後にお客様完了しました
やっぱでっ
ん
一番ください美音ちゃんと頑張って関東に来た後にお客様をわざといたしました
です
ありがとうございました
てできるため近くいいと思うんでこれすごいお勧めだと思いますまあ戻って背が高い
浮くなったときにみなさんにを書くと思います声のいつも使えたら便利ですよね
[音楽]
収納するとこれゲームサイズなんで
鍵はプレースプレー金を一応金属のでくっつくと思うんですよ
いきます
[音楽]
これまずよって来てね10ポケットから出してる時間になったら打たれちゃうんで打た
ねば敵を狙わなきゃいけないそういう時に
なんだこれ全部で何国で付けれるんだろう何でもつけそうな気がしてきてこれめっちゃ
つくめっちゃくっつく
松や梅でもうこれすごいする貨物機よと思えば何でもスターつけようと思えば何でも
付きますよこれマー[ __ ]だせえけどな
[音楽]
me
car
バッハ